They were exploring one of the most popular fads to hatch,
you heard me, since the pandemic.
Raising backyard chickens.
And some people don't know where to begin
but we've got you covered.
So it is time for Chicken Cooping 101.
(audience applauding)
(chicken clucking)
And joining us today is backyard chicken keeping expert,
Kathy Shea Mormino, AKA the chicken chick.
Hi Kathy.
Hi drew.
How are you?
What you got there?
I have your beautiful little baby here.
So I think you have Ebony,
and her partner Ivory is in there.
Now Kathy, raising chickens are all the rage
but were you surprised to see this trend
or were you like I've been here all along?
Well, yeah, I mean, I think backyard chickens,
I've been saying for years, are the new family dog.
So,
people looking to get back to our roots
you know finding out sustainability,
by way of growing our own food,
chickens for eggs, gardens et cetera.
It all makes sense that people want to know
where their food is coming from
and chickens are a pretty easy pet to raise.
(chuckles)
And, you know in the same way people started
making sourdough bread and banana bread during the-
(audience laughing)
You've got that Beyonce thing going like naturally.
Anyway, I need to stop looking like this
and be like, "Yeah."
(audience laughing)
I'm on the wings of an eagle.
I now eat all the eggs,
I'm extremely passionate about the chickens
because we raised them since they were baby baby chicks.
We gave them all names,
and I've been through several seasons with them now,
like full circle, they're over a year old.
Okay.
And that's them.
That's Blanch.
Of course it is.
Right, doesn't she look like a Blanch?
And then I've got Ramona, Percy, Pepper,
that's Ferdinand,
and we got all different, that's Pepper.
Now I love this coop design and I built a coop myself,
and I just basically took a garden shed and cut a hole
in the door, like in the wall and created a door
for them and just transformed it.
This is the chicest little coop I've ever seen.
What is this all about?
Well.
This is like giving me
Martha Stuart for chicken coop.
So go with that vibe,
but then build in safety and security and a couple
of things that are really important to remember
about chickens is that where they sleep at night,
inside the coop should be the safest place they ever are.
They have very few defense mechanisms
and if something gets in there, they're done.
They have poor night vision so they can't see a thing.
And so their chicken coop needs to be predator proof.
And we talk about predator proofing
with welded wire that's hardware cloth or welded wire.
I put a roof on mine,
because the hawks can come down and pluck them right out.
And I said, "No, no."
And I eventually, when it was safe
and I could have someone come to the house,
I built some boxes inside with little wooden ladders.
And it now looks like a professional chicken coop.
So now when you have a day off,
I want you to go in with your reciprocating saw again
and put windows on all four sides of your coop.
Really?
And a really, really important take home message
is the reason why,
because these birds have core body temperatures ranging
in the 104 to 107 degree Fahrenheit range.
And they're wearing down jackets all day, every day.
Now, Kathy, as we're gonna go into commercial,
I would love for you and I to make like a one minute pitch
for why having chickens are so great.
You go first, Kathy, give a one minute pitch
on why having chickens is a really wonderful thing.
So chickens are a wonderful thing
because they're the only pet that produces food.
And, everything else that they produced is also useful.
So their manure, once you compose it,
is amazing nitrogen rich, garden material
for your flower beds, for your vegetable gardens.
And they are just overall great pets.
They are the new family dog.
Kathy, I'm so glad I asked you.
And I second everything you say.
And I will also say that for me and my daughters
to raise these little baby chicks,
we all felt like parents together.
Whereas usually I'm their mom and they're the kids.
And instead we all became little mother hens
and I've just come to love them so much.
I love their eggs.
I love taking care of them
and it's simpler than I would have thought.
It seemed like a really daunting thing.
And it's actually brought me in
a tremendous amount of pleasure in life.
Oh, that's, that's wonderful.
And I hear that all the time and that's how it should be.
Well, I also think if you need a wind machine
at your next photo shoot, like, come on, here we go.
Ready?
Ebony is on it.
Ebony, give me.
Let's have it.
Let's Beyonce this.
Ebony, there we go.
I just wanna thank you, Kathy,
and the fact that your top is yellow,
the signature color of our show
matching these beautiful yellow reads.
you've brought so much joy to our show
and I really do encourage people to have chickens.
My pleasure and everybody starts somewhere.
None of this is intuitive.
These birds don't come with a manual
when you pick them up at the feed store,
when show up at the mail room.
And,
but you can read my book.
So there's that.
So there is, there is a manual now,
but there wasn't when I started.
What is the name of your book, Kathy?
We wanna put it on our website.
Absolutely, it's
"The Chicken Chick's Guide to Backyard Chickens,
Simple Steps for Healthy Happy Hens."
Go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com to get Kathy's book.
I cannot wait. I'm gonna read it cover to cover.
Thank you, Kathy, so much.
My pleasure, thanks for having me.
And thank you Ebony.
(upbeat music)